now we are ready to pull product out
okay so if I say I'm at y equal u V it's
the product of two functions
okay so just to clarify right this is
just kind of an assignment that all of
these things are functions of X okay so
y equals UV is just my shorthand way of
saying Y of x equals U of x times V of X
okay now I'm gonna pull out this trick
here this trick here
right I want to go towards thinking
about this I want to introduce this
Delta X thing because that's the way of
me doing first principles really okay so
if I say Y of X plus Delta X okay well
these are the left hand side means
everywhere I see X I should put X plus
Delta X X plus a little bit yeah this is
U X plus Delta X me X plus Delta X so
far so good
okay now I'm actually going through
because I went through this process to
know that this really means y plus Delta
Y do you agree with that okay it's what
happens when you evaluate it at that
little bit further
well it's your original value plus a
little bit but now going up instead of
across okay I can do the same thing for
these guys it's just for different
leaves okay so I'm gonna have you plus
Delta u and V Plus Delta V okay you see
what I meant by the way when I said like
this can get more confusing no less
confusing
it's almost death by symbols believe me
there are worse ways of doing it I'm
giving you a simple one okay so if
you've checked out that's fine what you
really need to know is how to use it but
I really like where this goes watch
these things remember their actual
lengths their actual distances just like
you know dy DX and that kind of thing
the chain rule there are actual
fractions right so this I can expand
just say I spend any other algebra okay
just expand the brackets what am I gonna
get
yeah b+ u Delta V now I could write the
next term as Delta u V but that's a
little bit confusing because then it's
like what's the Delta on is it on you or
is it on you V I want to avoid doing
that so I'm gonna write this as V Delta
u that's that's those two together does
that make sense then my last piece I've
got to dr. things hanging out Delta u
Delta V they're both very very very tiny
distances but they're there now just
pause for a second make sure we've
expanded this right hand side correctly
to you by two four terms or checks out
you're happy but there's something I can
do is this is the left hand side is it
not do you see some common terms you can
take a look carefully I only have a few
lines on the board what was my very
first line by definition why is the
price of those two whatever function
they are you and me and I have Y here
and I have UV there see that okay so I'm
going to eliminate it from both sides I
have Delta y equals this okay pause now
remember where I'm going you know where
I'm going cuz I read down before I'm
going here and this is where I'm going
okay so I need to do a couple of things
to this number one I've got all these
deltas
I don't want deltas I want I like well
yeah yeah dashes which is really Dion DX
yeah that's what I'm going towards in
order to do that get rid of the deltas I
need to apply limits you see that's the
difference between deltas and when
you've got D properly then the
difference is the limit okay but not
only that do you notice steady here wow
this looks so close to that line with
one problem I have this interloper
hanging around do you see that you Delta
V corresponds to UV
- you see that you you this Delta V
would become DV on D X it would become
that's right and this guy V Delta u
corresponds to V u - V D U and DX they
they make sense they look like they
should be there but what's this guy
doing over here so to show you where he
goes I have one huge missing piece right
I have all these Delta's but I'm missing
the really important one what I'm
actually differentiating with respect to
does that make sense
I don't know X is anywhere so I'm gonna
divide everything by Delta X I'm gonna
divide this one by Delta X this one by
Delta X now when I come to this guy on
the end okay something interesting
happens I could divide it by Delta X
that would work okay but I have two
things here right it's kind of like
chain rule where I had two things on the
top I should have two things on the
bottom shouldn't I so it actually kind
of makes more sense to divide this by
Delta X and in addition but this is part
of a derivative and then this guy should
also be part of a derivative do you see
that so I've got a Delta u 1 Delta X
that would become D or D X and then I
have Delta V M Delta X which would
become DV DX ah but I have a problem
this is a product right so this term on
the end I have not actually divided by
Delta X have I I've divided it by Delta
x squared so I I haven't done the same
thing to that as I had to all these guys
so to compensate and this is actually
the stroke of genius which is very hard
to see otherwise to cook and say I
multiply by Delta X on the end now
that's a bit weird you're like why why
divide by an extra time and then
multiply by another time to counteract
that okay well he is why he's one
what's the difference between having it
in deltas and having it in 2 Delta V
Delta Y Delta X bestest do you wanna do
and the answer is the limit it's the
limit right okay so I'm going to apply
limits now to everything everything
watch let's let's let's write it all
that now you see it right okay okay
limit as Delta X approaches 0 because
that's what I'm gonna do to everything
to get some derivatives out of this
right Delta Y on Delta X okay there's a
limit the limit as Delta X approaches 0
of this thing okay now see that you
there right it's independent but I'm
gonna I'm gonna write it in there so you
can see and I'm just going to write it
outside that fraction she's actually
different done okay plus limit there's a
limit to okay but they're all the same
limit V Delta U on Delta X one more
limit that guy's gonna approach zero and
then I have this mess okay Delta u Delta
X Delta V on Delta X and then Delta X
okay now let's just go through this one
step at a time by definition that's
dy/dx
yeah it's dy on DX okay now what happens
in here right what happens as Delta X
approaches 0 to this U is just you
whatever you is right so we you but this
guy on the other hand this is the
derivative this is the gradient function
DV on DX right so let me say that again
you know we thought about like you know
what's happening to a normal function a
normal function like say say this guy
right as Delta X approaches 0
you're just approaching the function
itself okay so the limit as Delta X
approaches 0
you it's just gonna be you okay so
that's why he just stays there unchanged
whereas this guy this is exactly this is
a rise over run the situation okay so
therefore as the rise over run tends
toward that infinitesimally small slot
you don't get a seek anymore you get the
actual tangent that's the gradient of
the pager same thing happens yeah now
look at this troublesome guy on the end
he's always a trouble child every family
he goes to zero because of this guy
which we were like was he there what's
he doing well he's multiplying
everything vanishes away I could write
plus zero but I don't need to genius and
this means that y dash is that's all
right I'll write this one first because
that is view - and that's UV - okay I
think that's amazing